the next story today about russian
prisons is that wnba star brittany
griner
has been sentenced to nine years in a
russian jail for drug smuggling now
remember the drug smuggling was under a
gram of cannabis oil
american women's basketball star
brittany griner was convicted of
deliberately smuggling drugs into russia
sentenced to nine years in a case that
is raising concerns that she's being
used as a political pawn in russia's war
against ukraine the judge delivered the
sentence and fined griner a million
rubles that's about sixteen thousand
dollars she said the court took into
account griner's partial admission of
guilt remorse state of health and
charitable activities
prior to the verdict greiner apologized
and asked for leniency quote i never
meant to hurt anybody i never meant to
put in jeopardy the russian population i
never meant to break any laws here i
made an honest mistake i hope that in
your ruling that it doesn't end my life
here i know everybody keeps talking
about political pawn and politics but i
hope that that is far from this
courtroom
i want to say again i had no intent on
breaking any russian laws i had no
intent i did not conspire or plan to
commit this crime she's been there six
months already
she is accused was accused of trying to
smuggle less than a gram of cannabis oil
in her luggage she pleaded guilty
and nine years now the u.s state
department is continuing to say that
this is a wrongful detention the biden
administration is continuing to
negotiate for her release and regardless
of what she says it has become an
explosive political situation now i want
to take a step further on this something
we mentioned on yesterday's bonus show
and i'm going to mention it again
there is a contingent of the
pro-authoritarian right-wing
that
is reacting to progressives like me
saying
this is an example of the way the
russian justice system works
99 conviction rate outrageous sentences
for minor crimes all these different
things there's a group of right-wingers
who sort of likes authoritarianism and
also likes the war on drugs
that is saying you hypocritical
progressives you just want to criticize
putin and russia
and you don't say anything about the
fact that here in the united states we
also imprison people for cannabis don't
you care about that yes i do and i've
been talking about that for a decade
the fact that in the u.s we are i
believe unjustly imprisoning people for
cannabis possession
minimum we can go beyond possession as
well
um
that's not less of a problem because of
what's happening with brittany griner
russia is a different situation
where
the the entire picture of the judicial
system involves
everything from
uh
planted evidence prosecutions a decision
made a priori that this is someone we
need to imprison let's create charges
and the trial itself is a sham and of
course we have elements of that in the
united states but in the united states
the main problem
is
how we handle
drug possession and so-called drug
crimes and i'm against both so don't
come to me with this oh you're only
talking about it because it's an
opportunity to criticize russia
absolutely not we criticize it here in
the united states as well the dynamics
are different so now the hope becomes
a political solution i mean at this
point it doesn't seem as though the
solution is going to come from any other
place let me know what you think you can
find me on twitter at d pacman but
extraordinarily disturbing news
the science has shown us that one of the
ways to achieve consistent deep sleep is
to lower your core body temperature at
night it also is just really
uncomfortable to be too hot when you're
trying to sleep our longtime sponsor
chilisleep makes customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions that improve
your sleep by keeping you cool at night
chili sleeps cube and ooler sleep
systems are hydro powered mattress
toppers they fit on your existing
mattress and they provide the ideal
sleep temperature
you can keep your bed as cool as 55
degrees or as hot as 115. i like 62
personally
stop waking up hot and sweaty in the
middle of the night with chilly sleep
you'll stay cool all night and stay
asleep you're really going to experience
a totally different bed when you install
this thing chilly sleep has been a total
game changer for me i didn't even know
it was possible to cool your bed down
like this before discovering chili sleep
is fantastic and chili sleep is the only
company on the market doing it like this
you'll get thirty percent off your new
cube or uhler sleep system at
chilisleep.com
pacman the link is down below